this program is being presented to you
by the heras international winter school
on gravity and
light welcome to the fourth tutorial of
the William and El Heros International
winter school on gravity and light
today's topic are differentiable
manifolds
we start with 15
statements a the function f that goes
from R to R defined by F ofx = x^2 lies
in
C3 where C3 means the function that lies
in there
is three times continuously
differentiable so we can
do the first derivative that's 2x the
second one is two the third one is zero
and all the others are 0 to but all the
derivatives are continuous therefore
this is
true now the function f is defined by f
ofx equals absolute value of
x and we should judge whether this lies
in C2 or not but if we
draw the function
absolute value of x we see that there is
a kink
and surely here it's not differentiable
therefore the second one is incorrect
third statement
is the function f is now defined as the
absolute value of x to the^ of 3 and we
have to judge whether this is in C3 or
not we need to draw this again
so that's the
function clearly we can derive it
once and we arrive
at this
one that's on the positive xais just 3 *
x^2 and on the negative xais we have
minus 3 *
x^2 so this is the first derivative the
second one
produces this one and this one where
this is 6X and this is min -
6X and there's a king and therefore it
lies not in
C3 the fourth function that's given is
the exponential function of the absolute
value of
x and this statement says that this lies
in C Infinity but when you draw this you
see that at the zero there's a king
again and therefore it's
false the last one is the logarithm the
natural logarithm of X but the domain is
now restricted to
r+ so the picture
is this one and if we restrict this to
our plus this is of
course infinitely often continuously
differentiable therefore that's true
B which statements on differentiable
manifolds are
true every smooth manifold has a maximal
atlas that's
true because a
manifold needs an atlas that covers the
whole
manifold or the whole topological space
and then it's a manifold and a smooth
manifold just gives some statements on
the transition functions
and any Atlas can be made into a maximal
atlas and therefore every smooth
manifold has a maximal
atlas every C2 manifold is also a C1
manifold that's
true because every function that's C2 is
also
C1 every differentiable manifold is also
a topological manifold of course because
different means the manifold is c k
let's say k greater or equal than one
and topological means that it's c0o and
that's
true now comes a tricky one in C
Infinity
manifolds chart maps are
differentiable in order to say this we
need to think about it and here's more
space therefore we draw a
picture now we recall that
a
function that goes
from some domain U some subset of the
manifold into
Rd this function f is called
differentiable
if the chart representative of this map
F here oh sorry I wanted to say the
function f goes into
Rd and now some chart
let's say x Tilda goes into rd2 because
that's a d dimensional manifold and F is
called differentiable if this map here
so f after X to the inverse is
differentiable then we call F
differentiable so now we have a special
case and the special case is we pick
fals x x the chart map that we want to
look at this chart map and as well we
pick X tiller equals
x because we can take any chart we like
because we have a smooth
Atlas And if we now consider this
expression with the special cases in
there that's X after X inverse which is
of course the
identity on
RD that is clearly the fr
ible therefore in a c Infinity manifold
chart maps are
differentiable the definition of a CK
curve on a manifold one should say
requires a c m larger than K
manifold that's true because we need the
atlas to be at
least CK when we want to judge the CK
differentiability of a curve
therefore this is true as
well c a differentiable manifold is
always a topological space that's true
since by adding the atlas we of
course keep the topological space so it
stays a topological space but gets more
structure by becoming a
manifold the second one is a
differentiable manifold has enough
structure to constitute a Vector space
of course
not a differential manifold is a
generalization of a set no it's not it's
a specification of a set but not a
generalization a differentiable manold
requires the discrete
topology no it doesn't it can carry any
topology that it
likes a differentiable manifold features
at least one set of charts that cover
the whole manifold or that covers the
whole manifold and that's true because
that's the idea of an atlas every Atlas
has to cover the whole
manifold so C the last one of C is
true and we move to the next
exercise we continue with exercise two
and now the topic
is the Atlas and the way from
topological to differentiable Manu f s
we start with the topological space r
equipped with the standard
topology and we further have an atlas a
containing two charts each of the charts
cover the whole manifold but they can of
course be together in an
atlas the chart maps are given by the
map X which is the identity map and the
map y that Maps some element a of R to a
to the power of
three and we should now construct the
transition map the chart transition map
y after X inverse and give the
differentiability
class so the picture here would be the
following let's say this is
R it's just a set so we can draw the
circle or whatever I like and we have
two
Maps first one's X second one is y and
these Now map
to the real line
r and between these two chart targets we
have the chart transition map y after X
inverse and that's the thing that should
be calculated so y after X
inverse takes some element a that comes
from r
and we can simply calculate this that's
y of X inverse but X inverse is the same
as X because it's the identity therefore
here's just an A and Y Maps this to a
the^ of
3 and of course a to ^ of 3 is C
Infinity R to R so this is a smooth
charge transition map in the One
Direction now we consider the other
direction so we are constructing X after
y inverse plug in some a that lies in
R this is now given as X of Y inverse is
the third
root of
a and the map X does nothing
so that's what
remains we may draw this in order to
judge the differentiability class and
the picture is the following
so here we have
infinite well the tangent is parallel to
the Y
AIS and of course if we do the first
derivative then we have a pole in here
therefore this function is not even
C1 it's c0 that means
continuous on
R and what we see now
is R equipped with the Senter topology
and this Atlas as it is given up here
this one is not a differentiable
manifold so here no
but and this was mentioned in the
lecture that by
restricting a an atlas of a topological
manifold which this was or is we can
make it into a differentiable manifold
so the question is what do we have to do
in order to make our o standard with the
atlas a into a smooth manifold and the
answer is simple we just remove one of
the
charts remove one of the
charts and it really does not matter
which
one because if we remove one only one is
left it stays an atlas because it covers
the whole
manifold and since there are no chart
transition maps of course this is
smooth therefore we made R equipped with
o standard and this new Atlas we made it
into a differentiable or even smooth
manifold that's it for this
exercise let's continue with the third
exercise that is an exercise on soft
squares on R cross
R so we have a set R cross r or R2
equipped with a soft Square topology and
then add a containing charts un
xn and these un n are given by the soft
squares that also Define the soft Square
topology that means all tuples in R
cross R where the absolute value of each
of the entries is smaller than some n
and here we just consider n from n plus
therefore for just positive integer
numbers so to draw a picture this may
look
like this is
U1 there's
one this
is
U2 and so
on okay and the chart map is given here
so in the first entry we sum X and Y
divided by 2N and in the second entry
the same thing but with the difference
of these two
first exercise is to recall the
definition of a chart and show that un n
xn are indeed
charts so the first thing we need to
check here is unu n an element of the
topology and that's clearly the
case because that's just the way the
soft squares are
defined second thing we need to show is
that the chart maps
are
homeomorphisms homeomorphisms that means
the
xn that go from u n to X of U xn of un n
part of
R2 these need to be
homeo
morphisms which means they are in vable
and in both directions
continuous so we consider the direction
unu n to xn of un this is clearly
continuous because we have the sard
topology
and well I I think that's clear the
other direction we need to calculate the
inverse that goes
from X and of unu
n into unu
n so it
picks
tups and they are mapped
to now we need to calculate the inverse
functions and I did this already and
this is n * A + B and N * a minus
B and these are are of course
continuous therefore U xn are
charts second question is um we should
show that
a is a CK Atlas by explicitly
constructing the chart transition
map or the chart transition Maps between
any
charts and then State what
K is so a chart transition map
is some
XM that belongs to the Chart U
mxm after another chart map I draw the
picture in a minute and we need to have
this from xn of u n
sorry inter Ed with u m and this goes to
XM of unu n intersected with u m and
here's the picture we
have here's the manifold we have
X sorry that's
xn we have the chart map xn and the
chart map
XM and this
is the chart transition map here's R2
and there's R2 as
well okay so in order to construct this
map we feed it with a tle
a and just plug these in here and
calculate the
result so this is XM
of xn
inverse we calculated here therefore
this is just n * A + B and N * a minus
B and the other direction was
given up here
so need to plug this
in and arrive
at now this
is M over n I'm
sorry that's wrong so it's
n over
M and here we have x + y But A + B plus
a minus B is just a and here the
coefficient is the same and B
remains therefore we can write this
shorter as n / M *
AB so we see the chart transition map
and notice we have both directions in
here since we did not specify M and N
therefore that's the most General J
chart transition map that's possible
here and therefore um we see that this
is of course smooth because it's just
the identity map maps AB to AB with some
Factor but but this does not matter and
does not infect the
differentiability therefore we can
conclude that K is infinity we have a
smooth
manifold the last thing to do here is
the third question and it says construct
at least one other chart that would lie
in the maximal extension of a and prove
that it
does so by maximal extension
mean we can add as many charts as are
compatible to the other charts and by
compatible we mean c Infinity
compatibility that means the chart
transition functions have to be C
infinity and we think of an example
that's really just an example you can
pick any other one call it X tier that's
the chart map and the chart domain is
say U five does not really matter but I
picked u5 and this goes to xer of u5
which is clearly a subset of R not D but
R2 okay and now I have to tell you what
the map does it takes two buils from the
manifold and Maps them
to well just itself pick the identity
map but that's clearly another chart and
what needs to be checked now is whether
the transition functions to any other
chart or from any other chart to this
one are smooth and we can write them
down this is in the first place X tiller
after xn
inverse and this one takes some A and
B and this is mapped to
A + B / 2 N A minus B over 2 N maybe you
need to construct this but that's the
right result and this is of course
smooth and the other direction which is
xn without the inverse the inverse gets
here goes here and we again plug in some
A and B and this
is a + b
sorry the inverse was
missing oh I did this the wrong way
around I'm really sorry I need to
correct
this so this has to go and this has to
go because here we have the inverse of
the chart maps that we defined above
that means this is n * A + B and here n
* a minus B and now here we get this A +
B over 2 N and here A minus B over 2 N
and this is again smooth therefore we
added a chart to the atlas that of
course would lie in the maximal
extension of the
atlas that's it for the third
exercise we continue with a very short
exercise four um but it's important
because we introduce a good notation for
part
differentiation we have a map F that
goes from RD to R and denoted as d sub I
on F is the partial derivative with
respect to the E entry but the important
Point here is this object so the
derivative of f with respect to this
entry is again a map in its own right
and again a map from RD to R
to see this we are given a function f
from R3 to R3 and it's it looks like
this and we have to calculate some
derivatives to calculate the second
derivative of
f
is that means we derive in this special
case with respect to Beta that means
this is two 2 Alpha to^ 3 * beta + 2
Beta Delta + 0 but as I said this is a
function in its own right and it's
evaluated at XY Z therefore the result
is 2 * x ^ 3 * y + 2 y
z we do the same thing here calculate
the derivative with respect to the first
entry and this produces 3 Alpha squ Beta
squ but evaluated at Square cir
star therefore we have
three Square squared time cir
squar so
really we first take the derivative and
then we
evaluate at some place
now we take two derivatives after each
other why not so the first one del2 on
F we had this before so this was 2 Alpha
to^ 3 * beta plus 2 Beta Delta and now
we derive again with respect to the
first entry now which was Alpha here
therefore what remains is 6 Al Al s *
beta but we evaluate at ABC therefore
the result is 6 a^ s
b and here we
perform two derivatives of the third
entry which is Delta so the
first is Delta up here so the first
derivative yields beta 2 + 1
and we derive again with respect to
Delta that's zero and therefore the
result is zero but not because we
plugged in the numbers first and then
derived some constants which he zero but
it's zero
because the second derivative itself was
the zero
function so that's it for partial
differentiation and we will apply this
in exercise
five last exercise for today for this
tutorial and it's exercise five on
differentiability on a
manifold the subtitle is how to deal
with functions and Curves in a chart and
we will draw diagrams here or one big
diagram and this is a really important
thing because visualizing these Maps
always helps we start with the smooth
manifold M Moa that is D dimensional and
we have a chart
ux from the atlas a together with a
smooth curve that goes from R to the
Chart domain and a smooth function that
goes from the chart domain to
R the first question asks us to draw a
commutative diagram containing the chart
domain chart map function curve and the
respective representatives of the
function and the Curve in the chart so
we
start as we always start with the
manifold
M we have a subset of this manifold
that's called
U on this manifold we have a curve
gamma which takes real numbers and Maps
it to the manifold could draw something
like this and that's the curve gamma but
we don't have
to we also have the function f
that goes from the subset U into the
reals we've also given a chart X this
one up here that of course goes to
some subset of
Rd so we drew chart domain chart map
function and curve what's missing are
the representatives of function and
curve in the
chart so we want to talk about the curve
gamma in the
chart and that's this one so everything
that's been in the manifold before is
now pushed down into the chart by the
chart Map X and this arrow is X after
gamma therefore X of the gamma is the
chart representative of the curve gamma
and similarly we have the chart
representative of the function f and
that's f after X inverse so we go up the
other direction of X and with the
function
f these are the two chart
representatives of function and
curve and again to emphasize that that's
an important technique in order to
understand these
things next question and that's the last
one for for today um asks us to
calculate this object so the function f
after
gamma derived some parameter Lambda the
first question we should ask is does
this make sense so deriving f after
gamma therefore we have to look from
where to where it
Maps can look at the diagram so it
takes it first takes gamma the values
the the domain of gamma which is
R is mapped to U and after that we take
the function and map it to
R
therefore this one is a map from R to R
and therefore derivation differentiation
makes real
sense and to do this we start here
f after gamma Prime of
Lambda
equals we would like to use some chain
rule because we have an outer function
and an inner function but the problem
is these
functions have Target and domain in the
manifold and there we have no notion of
differentiating therefore what we
do is we use the chart
Representatives so we go down in the
chart by the chart representative of
gamma and up to R again with chart
representative of
f therefore f after X
inverse after X after gamma and you see
this is a one therefore that's of course
the same as this side and since the
composition of maps is associative we
can set brackets
here okay in order to make this a little
simpler we Define this
one as capital F and that one as capital
gamma just to keep notation
simpler and now we want to apply the
chain
Rule and the formula goes like this so
Del I we derive with respect to the I
component and we derive capital
F evaluated at
Gamma of Lambda so that's the outer
function so to speak evaluated at the
inner function and the chain rule tells
us this should be taken times gamma the
I component of gamma
derived at the point Lambda
and since we know F and Gamma because
this is just Capital GMA and this is
capital F we can plug these in and
calculate the
result okay so deriving f with respect
to the first component
yields 2
x we would have plugged in X and Y but
we plug in
the capital gamma which is cosine s so
we evaluate this derivative at cosine s
that means we have 2 * cosine of
Lambda but times the derivative of the
capital
gamma of the E component and we are of
course here it's summed over we had this
before and therefore this is one
deriving the first entry here yields
minus
s of Lambda that's the first summon and
the second one is similarly similar we
have 2 * y but evaluated
at here so we have
S of Lambda times gamma 2 Prime is
cosine of Lambda and you see this minus
sign cancels the second term and
therefore we have
zero maybe you could think about this
because the curve gamma in the charge so
this Capital gamma describes a circle so
we have a circle where we run around all
the time with the parameter Lambda
increasing and the function that we look
at when we run around is x^2 + y^2 but
on the circle this is always one so the
values of the function around the curve
along the curve are
constant therefore the derivative is
zero so that's it for today see you next
time